so um so robin and i ended up um
splitting an apartment with with a
couple of other actors
so you lived and breathed like the same
i mean you guys were eating together
were you hanging out together you and
robin you were
all working together we were all working
together
we were living together i was 17
i was 18 i guess when i moved in with
robin
and he had already been through college
so he was like 22 or 23
and five years doesn't make a lot of
difference between 40 and 45
but between 18 and 23 it's almost like a
different gender it is
yeah i was so much younger than him
in terms of life experience i mean he
was going
he was doing stand-up mine on the steps
of the metropolitan museum that's where
he would go
on weekends to make money
i would have been petrified to do that
at that point in my life
i i just couldn't do that um
and he was doing these um
performances during in school of these
characters he was a great great great
character
as you saw in like mrs doubtfire and
moscow on the hudson
um but that was really his strong his
strength was character
and he would create these characters at
the age of 23 he did like an 85 year old
man and it was totally convincing
he was lost in that man i also always
imagined him someone like me at the time
probably
running around the house naked doing
goofy things making everyone laugh
was he like that because i remember i
heard like i'm working mind he was
always naked walking around opening his
robe it was just different time it
wasn't
he wasn't trying to be a perv he was
just trying to be a fun stupid clown
you know he was a clown the thing about
robin that was a little uh difficult to
live with is it it never turned off
never he was always what you saw
that was not um
something that he turned on it was just
the on switch was always on
um and in the middle of the night you'd
wake up and you'd hear voices coming
from his bedroom
and there'd be different characters in
there like the whole family was in there
but it was just robin and he was just
having these conversations with these
characters
he couldn't turn it off and that got to
be hard to live with
do you think that was hard for him too
he knew it yes yes
um i think the reason he couldn't turn
it off was because
he was much more comfortable in that
skin than he was in his own skin
it was hard for robin to just be robin
i found there was one night
he he left juilliard early because of a
very very um
dramatic breakup
uh with a girlfriend in california
any other leaving and he would have
these
five hour phone calls with her in the
middle of the night
and that was back when you were paying
you know mob l by the minute
so this was this was insane what was
going on it was really insane
and the night that she split up with him
he had a meltdown
and i saw all of that performance
bravado manic energy
melt and he became this
shaking
keening
child the sound was coming out of him
that was like
the only word i can think of is keening
from the irish plays
um and all i could do was hold him
and just hold him there was nothing i
could say he was shaking
and i realized he was losing control
and i thought this is the closest i've
ever seen him be
honest be him he wasn't performing
and i was holding him like you would
your son
and um we just i was afraid to let go
so eventually
put him to bed but that was the most
intimate moment we ever had
the most honest moment we ever had and
we never spoke of it after that
because i think he was embarrassed i
could see that because everybody every
time you see him he was always on always
always on and that was a moment where
you're like he
did he doesn't have control right now
this is the first time in his life
and it was nice that you were there from
you